well
let's go back to our breaking news story
that plane crash in Nepal we can get uh
some more of that with ramayata limbo in
the capital Kathmandu so first of all
any word on what happened to the crew
and passengers
uh the team
um
60
um four crew members and the rest were
passengers apparently from nemoons to
read about 32 bodies have been recovered
um there's many more details are
emerging now
apparently visibility wise the weather
was quite good
um so it is
um it's really shocking and surprising
the news uh coming in at the moment
about uh I believe again of the
passengers are foreign Nationals
and they were two young infants two or
three young infants are on board two and
basically rescue
um rescue people are
um after science at the Army local
Administration police
would be I'm missing a work and the
Crash basically
took place in Pokhara which is a tourist
town about
six hours drive from Kathmandu and about
a 30 minute flight from Kathmandu and it
basically try
a city
um and rescue operations are of course
continuing but it's really um surprising
and shocking news for
um for many people and most of the
passengers on board
um
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much